what is happening to reject nation it's
Greg Alba here and it's John Humphrey
here so we're gonna watch the honest
trailer today for Blade Runner and all
those dishonest trailers fake new make
news Berto Rico's fake island yeah but
today's patron today shout-out is gonna
be for a JN Valente yeah we're gonna
part rip apart no it's the Betsy a
triple cut of his eighties classic
improved by a director's cut ten years
later and further refine by his final
cut in 2007 we could go Ridley sure you
know my gonna mess with the ending again
throw the voice-over back in and history
books he's the kind of cop used to call
black men
blade rotor and seeing that cut in 1982
audiences new Harrison Ford as the
charming rogue unsolo or the charming
rogue Indiana Jones yeah watch him ditch
the whole charming time is it detective
or sorting so Blade Runner and bounty
hunter part
awkward psychiatrist magazine as for why
that's called a Blade Runner shut up
it sounds cool so build with Paul's
memory and upgrade is cool in pointless
as giving your fleshlight a family
history and witness the breakout
performance of Rutger Hauer
a replicant who speaks in monologues the
actor wrote himself literally the only
time that's work since Apocalypse Now
and savor a film that saves its biggest
twist or last Deckard might be a
replicant - or is he maybe it's pretty
subtle and depends on the god
take the test yourself whatever everyone
acts like a sad robot anyway
get ready he's arriving at low as movie
is going to give you plenty of time for
that it's a pretty slow
and staring at Deckard staring at the
window of his car
[Music]
it's Moody its town detective story they
take their time cyberpunk pills and all
those times someone says enhance cuz
this ain't your dad's bright and shiny
sci-fi this one has brain and cigs and
hookers and stuff and forget about
plucky rebels fighting the evil empire
this one's about corporations making
your life short and meaningless and if
that's too dark for you at least the
umbrella sticks light up glowy so enjoy
this story that sees so clearly into the
future predicting our modern anxieties
about genetic engineering corporate
ownership and release God's unicorn
fetish that may not have done well at
the box office but broke the record for
the number of film geeks insisting it's
genius
alright come on guys it looks amazing at
all but this is film noir with bro buys
it did was perfect they wouldn't recut
it other times there is that worried
definitely she's first Billy Idol is
Finkle Adama will you four eyes Hey Los
Angeles two years from now
Oh God
bottom you know what's cool Harrison's
rebooting all his iconic roles but
there's not much left after Deckard how
long until we get Henry air force to
actually I totally watch that I would
one more Blade Runner we go boxes to see
his talking your billboard right gossip
and the rest of the cache mass our
definitive guide to both the original
movie and Blade Runner 2049 danger is my
middle name
actually it's bill oh shut up
job well done screen junkies done it
job well done indeed is a long movie
that does take its time yeah yeah yeah
yeah you know I don't love this movie as
much as everyone else loves this movie
it's kind of way I feel about Full Metal
Jacket I really appreciate him and I I
do like it however back fondly I don't
I'm not like I love got a watch at least
once a year
yeah you know I I've only seen the final
cut I've seen segments of the theatrical
cut the one with the voiceover whoo that
is terrible like the voiceover it's so
soft and they shot that voiceover only
because they thought that audiences
wouldn't understand man movie people are
stupid people are dumb if anyone knows
movies it's the people with the money I
saw like the beginning one and then I
saw the N one after Rutger Hauer is a
famous monologue from the movie and then
she goes to do like a whole like I don't
know why he said this to me maybe it was
because I got everything that the
audience is just thinking on the road
got to be on that knows he's got to make
sure everybody gets it yeah make sure
what I did find surprising cuz about it
you know like they're pointing out how
you know he's charming rogue Han Solo
charming rogue Indiana Jones that's a
big part of why I like his performance
and Blade Runner actually he's a human
being tired depressed guy and yeah he's
like this depressed dude who's really
doesn't not happy with his life I've
kind of glad he dialed back a lot of
life because he's still charming what
he's charming yeah yeah yeah he's still
got that Harrison Ford charm
but it wouldn't have proprietary was
suave the whole time I don't think it
would be the same move he's got like
this depressed detective charm things
like there's a film norm yeah exactly I
use these a film noir detective he's
drinking all the time he's down he's
kind of downtrodden yeah yeah it's tough
that scene when he does you know yeah
that about that was an awkward scene I
remember that scene whenever you watch
movies from like before the 90s at least
you're like well it was before the
nineties that was a great bit that's not
how good said word good match to it was
like John Bailey uses some of that so
that celebrity voice-over skill you know
one of the biggest cosplay costumes is
Deckard yeah the girl with the raincoat
when she gets shot and they actually
made that just for convenience for
protection for what she's going through
the candy glasses stuntwoman okay you
could clearly see as a stunt woman just
with a terrible wig on yeah but it's
such a memorable moment in such a dark
moment in the movie that I didn't even
really notice it the first time that it
was a stunt double who was going through
the glass I was so like enamored by that
actual moment but yeah it's a total
stunt double and sex machina yeah
Daryl Hannah you know how she's like a
gymnast in the movie there was a stunt
double gymnast and I saw footage of
where she was like she would get so
dizzy because god loves to do take after
take that she just eventually couldn't
do the flips anymore she just kept
falling over that they had to get a dude
to come in and like Pat him up and
everything so he can replace yes such a
man build that you could actually see
like based off his crotch like oh that's
a dude no even in the scene where she's
like twitching out like sometimes a shot
of that is the guy just really it's just
so in the moment in the movie that you
don't even notice the how many times did
they shoot I will really Scott loves to
do his retakes man doesn't make you
realize just how many movies that this
has inspired both you know anime
live-action yeah yeah overtime so I'm
hoping the new ones like an actual hit
they showed the box office mojo report
yeah and it's pretty well known that
like yeah it wasn't a big hit when it
came out and and then like there were
three cuts late there's two more cuts
after it's making me wonder that even
though there were views for blade around
20 49 I've been phenomenal like probably
one of the best reviewed movies of the
year so far I'm going what if it doesn't
do well yeah
the images are mind-blowing enough and
they've put enough into that ad campaign
and and people love Ryan Gosling yes I
would be surprised if it didn't at least
do well and and very much better than
the first one did he I heard Jared Leto
actually the contacts he was wearing did
blind him so that way her for life yeah
he's perfectly no provocation is movie
yeah Thank You Street junkies for
letting us do this thanks guys ow
oh wow thanks Hal
Hal Rudnick I'm appreciating me now
screech okie J and Valente today is your
shout out to this guy we have to have a
Google hangout with you your reward here
qualified yeah we need to give you a hug
or something
this guy's a fascinating man you ask him
any question the guy will give you a
very long answer and he's British so you
just imagined like yeah the accent way
you know it's more time I was trying to
avoid can't avoid it on mines giant
Ville untie a while ago ask this guy
where he was from and Koerner microsoft
word he wrote down 211 words my theory
for why jay and talked so much is
because he's probably a replicant yeah
crying not to be caught humans love to
communicate and humans are self-absorbed
so I will talk so much about myself so I
feel like he's just spewing out a lot of
rambles a little information that his
replicant brain has been installed with
and he's just trying to fit in with
Society
Jan you opened up a magazine there's a
naked woman there she's smoking a
cigarette her baby is breastfeeding how
does it make you feel you go to the
toilet you sit down to urinate then you
ask herself I am
man why am I sitting down to pee
sometimes more comfortable Jan you wanna
drink I can get you drink yeah thanks
for being a part about patreon buddy
guys subscribe to the real rejects click
on notification about follow dat John
Humphrey on Twitter and Instagram
hi we have t-shirts if you want to buy
them and and today check us out on
patron Joestar Joe uh Joe the karate
would Joestar how was it kicked his ass
the whole review kicked his whole ass
all every inch of a that's where I aim a
lot of people even in the crack people
go for head face body or if you're lost
times of you don't have anything you go
for the Rotch I go for the ass rectly
given anus